Mình làm tháng 1, B-A-T-C, Chính thái chương trình kéo xe mến phi trong phạm vi hai miếng kí lúc mết đầu tiên trên tòan miệng bác,
nhằm hỗ trợ kì thời gian phương tiện gặp sự cố sơ bữa báo.
Sau bạo số mùi một nhiều tướng đường còn gặp cục mộ, yêu cầu cứu hộ tăng ngành.
Chính cơ sở thí điểm tại tháng 1, hẳng trong những ngày đầu, B-A-T-C quy định bở giộng chương trình ra tòan khu vực để đáp ứng cao điểm bộ mữa báo.
Chương trình ác dụ cho mọi phương tiện ô tô bị thủy kích, chết máy hoặc hư hại gió thời tiết.
Khách hàng linh hệ tổng đại một chính không không, sau không một không hoàn động linh tục hai miếng bốn dờ mỗi ngày để được đều phối đội cứu hộ gần nhất.
Lực lượng trình hai gồm lại xe chương trách, đều phối viên và kí thật viên phối ở với các đơn vị đều phương,
qua đó rất nán thời gian tiếp cận hiện chường.
Ngài Việt Kéo xem miếng phi trong phạm vi hai miếng kí lúc mết tính tự vị chi gặp sự cố,
đối ngũ còn tư bệnh phương án sử lý kí thật bà đau.
Một tiêu là hình thành mạng lối kí hộ đồng bộ,
ăn toàn trong hệ sinh thái ra thông thông minh của VATC.